that's all them so they were fitted
skinny man no they just happen the whole
time I have never heard of t-series have
no idea what it is I don't know anything
about t-series except for the pewdiepie
t-series viewed where they're surpassing
him and following I grew up with
t-series like many indie kids
I discovered t-series it must have been
like 10 years ago I would describe it as
the biggest record label and t-series is
a big media company I think they make
movies and music videos like Bollywood
songs sort like a vivo of India or
Bollywood it sounds like a gaming
channel I think of like a type of sports
car this is the Lamborghini t-series 92
million subscribers 92 in terms of what
I have seen on a series and what I love
watching t-series content for India is
basically Bollywood music videos I mean
if you think of Bollywood music you
think of t-series they're pretty
synonymous so this first one is called
Simba and then there's like a lot of
names after it I just don't think I'd
really pronounce them correctly me too
oh the Lighting's good
Oh Oh God yeah is it a [ __ ]
whoa is this a trailer it's so colorful
damn those camera angles this looks like
a very expensive production I love Big
Dance a group number so the noodle
dancing simultaneously blue the color
okay it this is really well done
everything is so like sexy I also want
to say romantic belly her look sexy yeah
I feel like she's an independent woman
yes it was like if you want to be me got
fired though so these are other people
and there's like eight singers look at
them there is hopping like they couldn't
executed this without hopping so much
but they wanted to sexual hopping mm-hmm
I love this Alyssa I love me some
musicals
I agree I love me some musicals I love
me some like a dance number
yeah doesn't have to
music sort of seem so it's mostly film
music and music so a lot of popular
music and India comes from movies you
know it could be three or four songs and
at least one of them is gonna be a big
title track which is a mainstream pop
song or something similar so this one's
called Badri ki dulhania title track and
this one has over half a billion views
you could get it every what is so
beautiful and glamorous oh my god look
up her brows she whistles on points
that's not fair
this choreo is really good I love this
channel I really do - I'm like pretty
sold on this like I was I was expecting
something completely different it's
known for a really great visuals and
that would be the music videos I did if
you have never experienced you know any
music or anything like that I'm sure
it's a great gateway
a train transportation cute guys
sleeping on the train now the man is so
beefy it is there D by either oh no are
we fighting but you got some is that
blood yeah
suta falling for teacher oh she got
asking him this was like I don't know I
said I'm into this
I thought through this in my career but
there's this die I want to dance in the
rain and oh she's like stop playing
games
that's they're together and she's
jealous
he was talking to another girl well
that's why she hit some water all of
their voices and all these music videos
are so mesmerizing
it was really poetic yeah okay so
humping Tigers my god
he's whipping her why some BDSM stuff
she's going to get with this girl that
he actually likes and she keeps bobbing
her head in she's playing up and then
she get in the middle of them when they
talking about all this before
[Music]
so what first video was my favorite yeah
best production value would subscribe
approve approve I can't believe I've
never heard of it before but I'm gonna
go be one of the 92 million subscribers
now honestly I feel like I could
definitely see myself watching this
during work like right now I'm probably
after this I think G series is a good
way to introduce people to Indian music
and cinema what better way to like get
involved in the culture than the music
of it so yeah I think it's a great
launch pad for that
Bollywood they are so great and so
creative and they're really good with
their storytelling so it's like it's
cool to know that we do have access to
this if we were searching for its
representation I would have so much
pride knowing that like you know if my
culture had a YouTube channel similar to
this it would be the most subscribed
like I would be like oh yeah oh yeah
baby oh hell yeah
in summation these were videos and they
were very popular videos they're more
popular than anything I've ever made and
I hope that they're more popular than
PewDiePie
[Music]